bienvenue pour dimanche en politique en
bourgogne aujourd'hui nous allons parler
agriculture à quelques jours du congrès
de la fédération nationale bovine à
nevers la filière bovine est en crise
depuis plusieurs années de nombreux
éleveurs jette l'épongé
que se passe-t-il pourquoi la crise se
prolonge tél on en parle avec nos
invités dans un instant à tout de suite
et lunettes
toute une histoire à mort et qu'un vrai
savoir faire à savoir faire historique
c'est le berceau de la lunetterie à une
machine qui date de 1880 1900 qui sont
toujours en état de marche c'est le
passage du savoir de l'ancien vers le
vert le jaune dans cette région du haut
jura
voilà plus de deux siècles qu'on invente
et qu'on fabrique des lunettes à savoir
faire mais ils france chercher longtemps
que la lunetterie se sert un peu
l'écoutent quand même les lunettes font
de la résistance
lundi après le soir 3 sur france 3
bourgogne
[Musique]
il y a quelques jours j'avais mal à
l'épaule et je ne pensais pas pouvoir
assurer ce vol ni ses petites
turbulences appliquée matin et soir
voltaire ain plast contient un anti
inflammatoire qui se diffuse
progressivement pour soulager localement
la douleur
voltarène place tu es un médicament
contenant de diclofénac indiqué en
cadence légère ou contusions pendant 16
ans ne pas utiliser chez la femme
enceinte
[Musique]
sur sauldre points comme les boxers sont
à partir de 9 euros
le plus grand choix de sous vêtements
pour hommes se livrent au point comme le
site de sous-vêtements pour hommes
je sais que c'est dangereux
mais j'ai besoin d'être au coeur de la
vague
je me sens en harmonie avec la nature
comme jamais
des sensations qu'on ressent sur ce type
de veille
c'est dans ces moments là que je me sens
vraiment vivante
vraiment bien
écoutez ce qui vous fait du bien avec
une tasse de thé vert lipton intense et
rafraîchissant
[Musique]
sur france 3 les explorateurs de vos
régions arpents tous les territoires
pour vous emmener là où personne ne va
jouer ou là précisément ici en la barre
ailleurs et même au coin de la rue
fantastique c'est grandiose cet automne
or c'est totalement sur ''les bienvenus
vous étiez vous partout
[Musique]
les gens viennent découvrir une carte
postale et nous quand on essaye de les
faire passer derrière là on ne vous a
jamais fait voyager aussi loin en reste
1 aussi près les nouveaux nomades
tous les samedis et tous les dimanches à
12h55 sur france 3
[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique en bourgogne en direct et en
cette journée électorale à gauche et
bien nous allons aborder un sujet qui
concerne tout le monde l'agriculture et
plus particulièrement la filière bovine
dont le charolais est une est un des
fleurons
mais cette filière est en crise une
crise qui n'en finit pas et qui sera au
coeur du congrès national de la
fédération nationale bovine
ce sera mercredi et jeudi prochains à
nevers alors pourquoi cette crise est
interminable comment en sortir nous en
débattons ce matin avec nos trois
invités
d'abord une agricultrice qui vient
témoigner emilie jana bonjour j'ai alors
vous êtes éleveuse de charolaises en
côte-d'or et vous lancer avec des
associés la société leboeuf éthique vous
expliquer quel est ce projet emmanuel
bernard bonjour vous êtes responsable
export à la fédération nationale bovine
vous êtes éleveurs dans la nièvre
c'est vous qui organisez le congrès de
la fnb cette semaine ou la semaine
prochaine
et quelle est donc la fmb qui je le
précise fait partie de la fnsea oui et
puis jérôme goalard bonjour bonjour
cette porte parole de la confédération
paysanne en bourgogne franche comté et
vous vous êtes agriculteur dans le
châtillonnais rentrer dans le
châtillonnais en polyculture-élevage
haut rhin j'ajoute enfin que ce débat
est aussi diffusée sur facebook donc
n'hésitez pas à réagir et à poser vos
questions j'essaierai de les relayer
2016 une annus horribilis pour les
éleveurs c'est ce que dit le dossier
presse de la fnb emmanuel bernard quelle
est la situation exacte aujourd'hui
l'iphone et soit parle de 10000 à 15000
agriculteurs qui serait en quasi
faillite sur 70 minutes ça fait beaucoup
dans éleveurs oui effectivement mais
c'est plus la succession d'ailleurs des
mauvaises années avec une crise laitière
qui nous a finalement apporté beaucoup
de viande sur le marché suite à un
embargo russe un arrêt des quotas un
problème évidemment de gestion tous ces
flux et du coup les éleveurs de bovins
viande dont dont les éleveurs de
charolais sont les composants finalement
subissent les conséquences de tout ça
puisque sinon en termes de production et
en termes de consommation il n'y a pas
énormément d'évolution mais on est
polluée par cette crise qui n'en finit
pas du côté des éleveurs laitiers quoi
vous fait le même constat la
confédération paysanne cette crise dure
vérité les spectateurs vos internautes
peuvent se dire ah les agriculteurs ils
se plaignent toujours chaque année
depuis 40 ans est ce que cette crise
avait redorée elle est pire que toutes
les autres non je crois qu'effectivement
il ya une véritable crise parce que
enfin si j'ose dire l'élevage bovin et
je rappelle ici que là la bourgogne
franche comté c'est la troisième région
française un haut niveau de l'élevage
allaitant
donc c'est un enjeu considérable pour la
région c'est l'addition de plusieurs
crises effectivement les crises dues à
des crises politiques par des embargos
par là le problème laitier qui est très
liée il faudra qu'on en parle
pour expliquer sa est également des
problèmes sanitaires puisque la fc o
joue en ce moment le problème de la
tuberculose également tout ça plus les
problèmes climatiques tout ça
s'additionne bien entendu pour créer un
climat très anxiogène est très
défavorable pour les agriculteurs on va
vous avez fait quasiment fait le
sommaire de cette émission reviendra sur
plusieurs des points que vous avez
abordé et bill et jane alors vous avez
une ferme familiale dans l'eau soit
votre situation vous avez combien de
bête est ce que vraiment vous rencontrer
plus de difficultés car on va enfin nous
on a une ferme d'élevage avec
85 90 villages apparent à peu près notre
particularité c'est qu'on fait beaucoup
de ventes directes depuis plus de 20 ans
sur la ferme donc on a une particularité
nous on va dire nous protège d'un
certain nombre de toutes ces crises qui
touchent moi plus fortement tous nos
boucles nous pourquoi dans votre
exploitation et du coup voilà on est un
peu protégés par rapport à ça malgré
tout la côte d'or a un statut
particulier par rapport à des situations
sanitaires etc
c'est vrai que c'est très compliqué pour
moi c'est quand même plus ce qu'on vit
aujourd'hui plus la conséquence d'une
crise structurelle de choix politiques
qui ont été faits il ya longtemps et
c'est pas vraiment voilà on ne récolte
que ce grain de sel pour finir celle sur
le diagnostic est ce que tous les
éleveurs de viande bovine a rencontré
des difficultés ou est-ce que ceux qui
élèvent des charolais des limousines qui
sont des races voilà qui sont assez
réputés sont un peu préservé
voilà grande grande majorité des
éleveurs aujourd'hui est en situation
difficile que l'on soit finalement
naisseur où naissaient engraisseurs ou
engraisseurs puisqu'il ya plusieurs
métiers dont elle expliqué dans
l'élevage
vous avez des gens et la bourgogne est
une région représentative de des gens
qui font naître des animaux et pour une
grande partie qui sont exportés pour les
mâles le marché italien est un marché
évidemment prisés
et les italiens ont l'habitude
d'engraisser nos animaux sont très
réputés et pour les femelles
on a une finition en bourgogne est aussi
une finition qui peut aller dans les
départements de l'ouest de la france
parce que vous avez du maïs vous avez
les composantes agricole qui permette de
nourrir les animaux dans le morvan vous
avez du mal quelquefois à tout faire à
la fois le naître et ensuite engraissés
et donc vous avez des engraisseurs par
contre spécialisée dans d'autres régions
quelques-uns en bourgogne mais bon coup
dans d'autres régions ça nous soumettre
le témoignage d'un agriculteur il est de
bretagne de nous regarder s'il dit qu'il
allait regarder l'émission il a 36 ans
et il nous dit qu'il produit une
centaine de jeunes bovins parents je ne
vois pas le bout je pense que moi aussi
je vais arrêter avant de ne plus m'en
sortir il nous dit que cette crise leur
a détruit psychologiquement alors il
nous dit est ce qu'on sait quelle
activité
est ce qu'on sait dire par activité qui
perd le plus d'argent ce que sont les
naisseurs les naisseurs engraisseurs les
engraisseurs et nous ne parlons jamais
des engraisseurs et pourtant c'est celui
qui reçoit le moins de soutiens de la
pac se sont un peu abandonné régis a
priori ça vous pouvez me dire on peut
déjà comprendre sa situation parce que
engraisseurs de jeunes bovins
effectivement l'année 2016 notamment est
une année compliquée pour pour plein de
raisons et climatiques économiques
en même temps ce qu'on a c'est qu'on a
une difficulté à dire tel système par
rapport à telle autre fonctionne ou
fonctionne pas parce que sinon tout le
monde ferait la même chose vous avez une
diversité en france avec les races les
territoires des terrains difficiles des
terrains plus facile et tout est en
réalité on s'aperçoit que vous avez des
systèmes qui marche dans toutes les
races et des systèmes qui marchent pas
dans toutes les races mais l'histoire le
poids de l'histoire de l'est de
l'éleveur peut avoir beaucoup d'impact
le niveau d'investissements le prix du
foncier voilà le fait d'avoir eu ou pas
une catastrophe climatique tout ça a un
impact
évidemment chaque exploitation
individuellement quand même le plus tous
les éleveurs ce qu'est ce qui n'a pas
été évoqué c'est le prix enfin on allait
venir mais voilà donc c'est ça c'est sûr
que quand on prend en considération tous
les autres critères dans l'acte de
production et jamais le prix de vente
c'est sûr que forcément au bout d'un
moment c'est problématique parce que le
prix est trop bas
alors vos syndicats on vous a vu
notamment la fnsea souvent manifesté
devant les abattoirs les abattoirs
privés notamment aux joueurs on va
peut-être voir des images de blocage qui
ont été tournées à cuiseaux en
saône-et-loire pourquoi on s'en prend
aux abattoirs est ce que ce sont eux qui
sont responsables de prix comment ça se
passe en fait c'est ce qu'on vous pouvez
l'expliquer à nous en deux mots et
l'idée c'est de faire un point de
situation
mais vous avez eu concentration de la
grande distribution
voilà aujourd'hui vous avez 4 5
enseignes qui se partagent 60 % du
marché de la distribution de la viande
bovine
vous avez eu concentration du monde de
l'abattage pour x raisons normative
économique et tout est donc ça veut dire
que le rapport de force entre les
éleveurs qui sont je rappelle entre
laitiers et races à viande c'est 180
mille éleveurs en france donc il faut
évidemment le rapport de force et est
compliquée et par contre effectivement
on a aussi eu un certain nombre de
changements réforme de la pac
mondialisation et changement aussi dans
la consommation des gens donc ça c'est
aussi important et je pense qu'à partir
de ce constat là nous on fera des
propositions
voilà on a on a
des choses à dire après à partir de ce à
dire qu'il ya un seul interlocuteur
responsable de ça non les pouvoirs
publics ont permis la concentration ont
voulu cette concentration
il faut lui dire derrière on en subit
les conséquences
c'est le noeud du problème oui je crois
qu'il ya quand même un fort aspect
politique dans tout ça c'est à dire que
les grandes productions agricoles sont
aidés par l'europe par les régions et à
ce niveau là il ya des ya des choix à
faire et si on veut que notamment les
vaches bovins s'en sortent
il faudra l'accompagner il faudra le
soutenir dans ses rapports avec
effectivement ces groupes qui sont ultra
qu'au centre concentré et puis il faudra
également essayer de trouver une
démarche pour sortir par le haut et
sortir par le haut c'est sortir par la
qualité parce qu'aujourd'hui l'élevage
bovin c'est un colosse aux pieds
d'argile ça demande énormément de
capitaux aujourd'hui dans vous avez un
problème ou les exploitations sont d'une
telle taille qu'on n'arrive plus à les
transmettre
et si on cherche à absolument gagner par
la productivité entre guillemets et par
la quantité l'élevage ne s'en sortira
pas c'est pas possible il faut
absolument
alors il ya des des des solutions telles
que celles que va pratiquer et emilie
qui peuvent être une solution mais qui
sera pas forcément la solution pour tout
le monde mais en tout cas il faut viser
la qualité
c'est aussi votre avis alors on a vu
encore des manifestations à cette
semaine à agen notamment les
agriculteurs ont du mal à s'en sortir
mais alors expliquez nous par rapport à
ce prix parce que moi aussi je ne
m'abuse il ya eu la loi sapin de
maintenant qui impose me semble-t-il que
les contrats passés entre agriculteurs
et acheteurs doivent faire référence à
des indices public de coût de production
est ce que ça ça améliore les choses ou
pas on fait trop tôt pour le dire
puisque je crois qu'elle est entrée en
vigueur à la fin de l'année mais je
partage ce que disait emilie tout à
l'heure effectivement le prix ne prend
pas en compte de coûts de production qui
qui aujourd'hui produirait quoi que ce
soit sans dire ben au moins je veux
rémunérés
l'acte que je tousse que je mets en
oeuvre mais bâtiment et tout ça est donc
la loi sapin 2 et fit évidemment a pour
objectif de permettre de travailler
entre les distributeurs et les
producteurs ça c'est un élément un tout
petit peu nouveau c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on peut finalement créé
un partenariat de négociation où on va
organiser des échanges entre les
producteurs dans leur ensemble on n'est
pas obligé d'y aller tout seul parce que
la grande distribution c'est un monde
très complexe mais et est allé discuter
avec les enseignes et évidemment créer
des partenariats qui dure parce que le
souci c'est que notre production elle se
fait sur le long terme
donc on ne peut pas dire décréter des
choses comme ça pour la semaine qui
vient
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure il la
crise laitière dont il ya eu plus
d'abattage de boeuf si je comprends bien
il ya encore eu aussi des manifs à
bruxelles cette semaine beaucoup de
viande sur marché ça veut dire baisse
des prix alors est-ce qu'il faut pas
justement revenir sur ce volume est
comment faire du coup ce que vous aurez
une idée les uns les autres une solution
une solution
là évidemment que maîtriser les volumes
mais ça c'est un débat mondial c'est que
vous avez un mot
des situations où vous n'êtes pas
compétitifs et à un prix quelquefois
alors on veut pas prendre en compte nos
coûts de production donc on mange de
l'argent en même temps la demande elle
est là dans le monde
elle est là c'est une question par
contre de rapport de forces c'est
toujours un rapport de force et en
europe
vous avez des pays qui continuent de
nous prendre delà de la viande
régulièrement maintenant qu'ils
augmentent leurs parts de marché pour
venir chercher de la viande en france
parce que c'est le niveau qualitatif qui
les intéressent vous avez un prix et une
qualité
l'un en face de l'autre le volume je
dirais quelque part il veut pas dire
grand chose
la seule chose c'est que vous avez une
compétition permanente et que quand vous
avez des accords internationaux quand
vous avez des décisions politiques
voulaient subissent et quand vous êtes
sur votre élevage c'est ça la difficulté
et l'éleveur lui il ne peut s'adapter
que petit à petit on ne peut pas
décréter la production le lendemain et
du coup on crée des pistes et on demande
à des lois d'évoluer pour créer des
partenariats avec les distributions mais
tout ça prend trop de temps au vu de
notre situation de trésorerie et puis
j'allais dire c'est pas vraiment c'est
un peu comme si on demandait de changer
un tournevis cruciforme en tournevis
plat avec ses fameuses lois pour moi
c'est pas le fond sais c'est qu'on
devrait avoir une vraie politique
alimentaire de qualité et qui va de pair
avec une politique agricole
voilà alors les histoires de cours
mondiaux et de marché à l'export etc
ça fait aussi partie du problème ici
c'est à dire qu'on peut pas être à la
fois vouloir exporter à tout va ce qu'on
produit chez nous et en même temps qui
est au scandale quand la france importe
dans des accords de libre-échange quoi
c'est effectivement très compliqué bah
oui mais on peut pas imposer aux autres
d'absorber toute notre viande et donc du
coup ni leur souffle alors leur envie
légitime d'avoir une certaine
souviendrai souveraineté alimentaire et
puis se comportait différemment avec
nous-mêmes enfin je veux dire c'est un
truc de base quoi on n'impose pas aux
autres ce qu'on veut pas avoir à nous
mêmes donc enfin moi je pense que
vraiment l'alimentation ça fait trop
longtemps que ça a été en tout cas en
france
une politique qui a été pas vraiment
ambitieuse et elle va de pair avec
l'agriculture et donc si on veut
redonner du sens aux métiers des paysans
et redonner de la qualité dans les
assiettes de nos consommateurs et du
coup redonné de la santé aussi aux
consommateurs eh bien il faut faire les
choix qui s'imposent
il faut revoir tout le système c'est
votre président qui disait ça oui je je
je me redonner la santé oui enfin je
pense qu'on l'a pas perdue avec notre
alimentation quand même la chose qu'il
ya c'est qu'il faut effectivement
prendre le problème dans sa globalité et
et on a
donc ça c'est à la fédération nationale
bovine fait une analyse assez structuré
du marché et où finalement on a un des
races à viande en france qui sont le
fleuron quand même d'une tradition
culinaire de paysages et où on a
vraiment la limousine la charolaise la
blonde d'aquitaine et ça il faut
conserver ça il faut pas parler partir
dans des croisements à tout prix des
choses comme ça mais derrière l'idée
c'est bien et on a lancé l'histoire du
coeur de gamme
vous avez présenté sa au salon de
l'agriculture est au coeur de gamme
c'est quoi l'idée si vous laissez base
et on a on a trois objectifs le coeur de
gamme c'est de dire aux consommateurs
nous allons négocier avec la grande
distribution et essayer d'avoir un
partenariat continu sur le fait que vous
aurez un rayon viande dans certaines
chaînes donc aujourd'hui c'est signé et
s'est mis en place par système u par un
carrefour et les autres vont suivre les
réseaux qui vont et non pas le fait que
ces enseignes s'approprie le nom du
producteur à chaque fois l'image du
producteur est utilisée elle est usurpée
là on est vraiment éleveurs est engagée
dans la démarche est l'enjeu c'est
d'imposer plus de 50% dans les rayons
viande de ces supermarchés de races à
viande parce que évidemment moi je suis
pour la vente directe je suis pour les
signes de qualité
je suis pour tout ça il ya aucun
problème sauf que la majorité de la
distribution de la viande elle se fait
en ville et par la grande distribution
donc on s'adapte là dessus ça peut aussi
laisser pour l'élevage laitier parce
qu'il faut pas laisser l'élevage laitier
de côté on a on n'a pas de procès à leur
faire mais il ya la restauration hors
foyer qui se développe de façon
permanente la la restauration collective
publique c'est restera sur la qui
utilisent des produits surgelés qui
peuvent aussi utiliser des produits de
qualité mais la majorité c'est quand
même du quelquefois 2,8 steaks hachés
congelés là il ya de la place pour le
troupeau allaitant et l'export parce que
l'export est aussi là pour permettre
notamment
au mal qui naissent dans notre pays que
l'on n'a pas l'habitude de consommer et
sur lequel on a démarché autour de la
méditerranée notamment qui sont
intéressés et tout ça simplement en
disant que je ne suis pas contre
l'importation ou pro exportations mais
il faut que les importations prennent en
compte les objectifs qualitatifs et
sanitaires que l'on se donne chez nous
lehmann et rexona l'arrêt depuis des
années la réciprocité nous c'est très
bien ça marche pas depuis des années
après ces faits qu'est ce qui ne marche
pas et bien les importations lait la
viande importée elle ne subit pas les
mêmes critères de qualité que ce qu'on
impose aux éleveurs français
oui ça va pour le dénoncer au bout d'un
moment
enfin voila on sait qu' il ya des gens
qui trichent et ils trichent tout le
temps le problème c'est que pour les
éleveurs on leur a promis on leur a dit
allez dis faites des broutards et puis
on va les exporter ça va être génial
vous avez dit tout à l'heure la
charolaise etc c'était sa fin on sait
faire de la bonne viande en france
j'avais vous dire ben non excusez moi on
a perdu cette tradition d'engrais ce
moment en france quoi et c'est fort
dommage parce qu'on a tout pour faire
parce qu'on les envoie en italie c'est
ça oui oui on a encouragé les éleveurs à
faire du maigre beaucoup on n'a pas
encouragé ce qu'ils faisaient
enfin ce qui est problématique pour moi
c'est qu'on n'a pas encouragé les gens à
faire du nez sage de l'engraissement et
de la vente à aller jusqu'au bout de
leur production du coup ça rende ya des
gens qui font des messages et des gens
qui font de l'engraissement enfin on le
voit sur différentes filières pas quand
bof ça fragilise vachement ce système
est rentré vulnérables des crises
sanitaires mais aussi des crises
financières et ses traits c'est très
dommage et là du coup les éleveurs on
leur dit bon bah oui mais je vous
entends dire dans le morvan on peut pas
engraisser
là je vais reprendre un boucher yves
marie le bourdonnec qui est très connu
effectivement les anglais ils n'ont pas
de céréales pourtant ils font la
meilleure viande du monde
ouais bah ouais ils sont ils sont passés
par un moment très difficile quand même
les anglais je pense qu'on va aller
chercher 32 leçon de la part des anglais
parce que en matière
gastronomique ils ont quand même ils
sont passés par des alors c'était par
les éleveurs effectivement enfin on a
vécu on a eu des conséquences d'une
crise terrible en france qui vient d'où
d'angleterre par contre sur le fait de
dire il faut pas le broutard c'est un
animal qu'il faudra arrêter je regrette
on envoie 80% des mâles qui naissent en
bourgogne
et si on regarde les chiffres depuis
deux ou trois ans la chose qu'on a c'est
que c'est le broutard c'est l'animal qui
a le moins perdu d'argent aujourd'hui
dans son prix de vente
les vaches ont perdu beaucoup les
génisses les tout ce qu'on vend sur la
france a perdu en valeur absolue en prix
au kilo et le prix du broutard est resté
relativement stable à 1% près c'est là
où les éleveurs à quai mais vif
la question c'est est-ce que les
éleveurs ont tort de faire c'est parce
que je pouvais encore là j'allais dire
c'est plus en tant que chef des fn dès
que je m'adresse à vous c'est à dire que
quand on leur a dit faites du broutard
etc
allez-y effectivement du coup ils ont
perdu cette habitude d'engraisser leurs
animaux et de les vendre
fini gras et du coup effectivement ça
les rend aussi fragile de tous les gens
à qui on exporte fins et botha et donc
un jour y aller fc auch faut absolument
qu'ils soient vaccinés un autre jour
vivre encore une nouvelle maladie qui va
venir il va falloir se plier à ces
dispositions
enfin ça rend quand même hyper fragile
le jour du jour au lendemain si bas
comme la russie des scripts elle pays
décrète un embargo on fait quoi et dont
on trouve donné ce région ont produit un
million trois cent mille tonnes de
viande aujourd'hui en france à quelque
chose près on en importe 200 millions
n'en exporte 200 milles c'est à peu près
les chiffres 220 230 milles mais sauf
qu'on importe un type de viande qui
n'est pas produit en france et on
exporte un type de viande qui correspond
à la demande de pays
donc voilà je pense qu'un certain
équilibre et on exporte un million et
demi d'animaux vivant en espagne
notamment et en italie et ça c'est
pareil ces gens là de toute façon si
jamais ils vont chercher les animaux
ailleurs parce que effectivement ils
iront chercher les a ni moyens et et à
un moment donné
ils reviendront sur notre marché faut
pas croire que les frontières on va les
faire mais c'est impossible
j'en ai déjà vu la position de la
confédération paysanne elle le dire il
faut redonner à la ferme ce qu'elle
faisait à l'origine c'est à dire oui
grandir c'est à dire de toute évidence
enfin le système tel qu'il est y marche
pas entre entre 2010 et 2014
la bourgogne franche comté a perdu 10%
de ses exploitations d'élevage c'est
considérable
le troupeau a peu ou pas bouger mais
voilà oublier un centre à sion il ya une
concentration et la concentration
ça veut dire concrètement que c'est un
transmissibles c'est un transmissibles
et dans peu de temps on va dire
attention ce sont des investisseurs
extérieurs qui viennent investir qui
viennent prendre ces exploitations là et
on mettra maîtrisera plus rien donc il
ya un vrai danger là dessus 12 que ce
qu'on souhaiterait c'est que vraiment là
on remet en place cette notion de
qualité
le fait aussi de tronçonner les
productions sa instrumentalise les
animaux c'est à dire que c'est une
matière première au lieu d'être un
animal qu'on élève est con on emmène à
l'abattoir dans les meilleures
conditions possibles parce qu'on sait
bien qu'à la fin ce sera bien pour aller
à l'abattoir on est d'accord mais il
faut pas perdre de vue ce genre de
choses
et avec ce système là c'est
effectivement ce que disait milice est
extraordinairement fragile
alors où nous dit on trouvera d'autres
issues d'autres importateurs d'autres
lieux pour exporter mais ça ne se fait
pas dans un claquement de doigts il faut
plusieurs années pour retrouver d'autres
marchés et pour basculer à nouveau
et pendant ce temps là il y à des
éleveurs comme ceux naisseur bretons qui
sont en crise et qui ne trouvent pas de
solution pour survivre si on n'a pas les
chapes à thouars de l'export je vous
prédis une chose avec quatre acheteurs
en france ça va être encore plus facile
pour eux de décider du prix ça c'est
clair donc je pense que faisons
attention de ne pas avoir des soupes à
aider des endroits où on peut
exporter parce que on a tellement
concentrée la distribution et le monde
de la bataille que le risque c'est que
si on se referme sur nous mêmes soit
encore plus dont on va parler dénonce de
la baraque avec vous et venez pas avec
vous avez très bien concentré le monde
de la bête m'a parlé de votre votre
projet qu'est ce qu'il nous reste très
peu de temps que ça passe très très vite
mais avoue quand même parce qu il
insiste je me suis posé plusieurs
questions à ce propos pourquoi vous
parler de deux vaches qui doivent manger
du maïs pourquoi du maïs puis c'est vrai
c'est des herbivores cdu c'est un
végétal de maïs y a pas à dire pas de
problème non mais c'est revivant
herbivore herbe
ouais mais il ya aucun problème à donner
du maïs à une vache et la silla la
question aujourd'hui agent s'est posée
je sais qu on est on est dans une
situation où on a des signes de qualité
où on enlève le maïs ya aucun problème
là dessus et vous pouvez prendre le laos
et boeuf de charolles par exemple vous
serez sûr que l'animal n'aura pas manger
de maïs et la ccxr c'est clair ensuite
il n'y a pas d'interdiction a donné du
maïs à des baumes ça c'est évident et ça
n'altère pas la qualité de la viande
et si je l'aï ce ça a tendance à quand
même quand les animaux jouent coupe
excusez moi mais quand déjà et d'une
maille ce problème c'est effectivement
ça pousse pas facilement c'est une
culture qui coûte extrêmement cher aux
éleveurs donc conclusion des systèmes où
ils doivent mettre du maïs dans leur
ration salou coûte cher du coup ils
gagnent moins d'argent déjà et d'une
ensuite sur la qualité de la viande bien
sûr que si ensuite sur la qualité de la
viande par l'avant-centre et aux
bouchers mais les animaux qui mangent du
maïs souvent ils sont en acide aux et
les maturation de viande d'animaux qui
ont mangé du maïs c'est très compliqué
effectivement vous en parlerez à plein
de bouche et yves marie le bourdonnec à
hugo desnoyer et compagnie ils vous
confirmeront tout ça la viande nourris
au maïs pas les animaux nourris au maïs
c'est des viandes qui sont compliqués à
maturer et s'est pas conclue c'est pas
compliqué de faire manger de l'herbe à
des herbivores un mot quand même parce
qu'on a parlé de votre concept vous
lancée au salon de l'agriculture en
quelques mots expliquez-nous alors le
boeuf éthique c'est quoi c'est une unity
mobile vous et allez voir ça en sus il
existe en suède
pourquoi revoir
vouloir remettre de l'abattage en ferme
ça posait des problèmes sanitaires non
non pas du tout au contraire enfin non
non non aucunement pourquoi vouloir leur
faire c'est clair que quand on est dans
une démarche de production de viande de
qualité très vite on sait que l'abattoir
c'est une phase cruciale c'est à dire
que si les animaux sécrète des hormones
liées au stress la qualité de la viande
pareil au moment de la maturation va
être vraiment intéressé quand même
dommage quand les éleveurs passe deux
trois quatre ans 56 ans pour certains
animaux de les élever correctement pour
faire la meilleure vente possible que ce
soit gaspillé ont finalement quelques
heures juste avant la tuerie
donc après moi je suis sensibilisé à ça
depuis onze ans que je fais ce métier
donc je fais très attention quand j'ai
vu ce système en suède il est proprement
parfait pour pour que ça marche il faut
beaucoup d'éleveurs quand même parce que
oui vous allez à lait de ferme en ferme
avec lille c'est ça mais est-ce que
c'est rentable d'aller tuer une vache
dans une ferme et d'otages dans une
autre sphère oui alors effectivement
quand on va et d'une ferme à l'autre on
va pas tuer une vache chaque fois on en
tuera un certain lot d'une taille de
qu'on aura convenu avec les les
agriculteurs 8 ou plusieurs vaches en
même temps parce que c'est un grand
pilote
en fait le principe de notre société
c'est qu'on leur achète leurs animaux
vivants ont tu leurs animaux sur leur
ferme donc on transporte la viande est
pas les animaux ça change tout et
ensuite on vend cette viande sous notre
marque qui s'appelle le boeuf éthiques
donc pour les éleveurs en fait au lieu
de vendre à leurs maquignons ou alors
coopératif importe des animaux en lots
qui devront partir faire des kilomètres
pour aller à l'abattoir
la seule différence c'est que nous on
vient chez eux et voilà on leur achète
ce lot d'animaux et ce sera prêt quand
on démarre au mois de juin il nous reste
très peu de temps le congrès de la fnb
angot qu'est ce que vous allez dire le
ministre vient finalement je ne sais pas
si le ministre vient d'être venu à celui
de la confédération paysanne
ce que je sais c'est que xavier beulin
il sera et que en tout cas l'objectif
c'est bien de décider de notre démarche
éleveurs est engagé dans le coeur de
gamme et finalement les discussions
seront autour d'eux comment est-ce qu'on
reprend finalement du crédit pour aller
discuter de nos coûts de production
parce que de toute façon et c'est je
reconnais que l'abattage par exemple
mobile est un système où les éleveurs
veulent reprendre finalement en vain
leur destin en main c'est un système
très intéressant et c'était un projet
collectif intéressant mais ça il y en a
des dizaines
il y en a des dizaines et nous on
voudrait les pousser tous comme quoi il
y a quelques points d'accord même si on
a bien compris qu'il y avait plusieurs
visions de l'agriculture merci en tout
cas d'avoir accepté notre invitation de
temps passe très vite je vous rappelle
que vous pouvez voir ou revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet ou sur
notre page facebook
tout de suite place à l'info régionale
avec fabienne acosta et dimanche en
politique continue juste après francis
letellier reçoit de nicolas dupont
aignan mon dimanche bon appétit à tous
[Musique]